(energetic music)
- [Voiceover] When I'm juggling,
I feel like I have a superpower.
To me it's just an amazing feeling
to keep lots of things in the air
and to keep these big patterns going.
- [Voiceover] Sam Malcolm
is a combat juggler.
The object of the sport is to
keep all three pins in the air
while preventing your
opponent from doing likewise.
Light bumping and arm-to-arm
altercations are permitted.
The last juggler standing wins.
(upbeat music)
- I got into combat juggling at about 3am
at a juggling convention,
playing around with some friends,
just trying to see who could
be the last one standing.
We've all been to circuses.
We've all seen variety acts.
But this is something that
makes it more of a sport.
If you're playing football,
you have to put in the work
to get good at football.
Juggling is no different.
You have to put in hours and
hours and hours of practice.
You're not only accounting
for the three objects
that you're juggling,
you have to anticipate that
there could be something flying
at your head from 50 feet in the air,
because it's so wild and crazy.
There's so many other people playing.
(audience exclaims)
(upbeat music)
I warm up for combat juggling.
I jump rope for about 10 minutes.
I work on balancing things
with my head and on my face.
There's a lot of wild throws.
There's a lot of wild saves.
There's a lot of jumping
around and falling
and running on the ground,
and I try to go through all
of those things to get ready.
You see incredible plays
by people like Steph
Curry or LeBron James.
I can look at those people and tell you
like they'd be great jugglers,
'cause they have that awareness
over (laughs) their body.
It's something new and exciting and fresh.
It's something fun.
It's something different.
(audience exclaims)
So I'm optimistic that it'll grow
and become something really great.
(upbeat music)